if I ever hear my kids say the word
failure
I locked them in a room for a week
you've got to be able to have a very
clear vision of your business idea
working out of 12 foot by 12 foot was
tough but when you happen to live there
as well
it makes it that much harder if a
description of his own entrepreneur is
that I want to do it all before I die
then I'm at research of feasibility are
fundamentally important when starting a
new business a new business venture will
require the majority of your time effort
and dedication and actually say that for
an entrepreneur this is the time so many
people talk about doing something or say
what if successful entrepreneurs have to
undeniable qualities determination and
persistence I don't have to work 16
hours a day I love working 16 hours a
day he's a British entrepreneur with
interests in media mobile phones leisure
and property he was appointed commander
of the Order of the British Empire in
2009 his estimated net worth is 475
million pounds he's Peter Jones and here
his top 10 rules for success I mean I've
got a real belief and this is a true
belief and if those of you everybody's
got kids out there if I ever hear my
kids say the word failure I've got them
in a room for a week and I I would
request if we have any power in this
country that we could take that out of
our English dictionary and replace it
with the word feedback yeah because
that's all failure in our words is isn't
it
it's feedback we learn from mistakes
you've got to be able to have a very
clear vision of your business idea
without it you won't actually know where
you're going so in the year 2000 I set
up generation telecom and generation
telecom was a business that supplied
airtime to the rail users I believe that
I could set up and manage this business
and within two or three years sell out
to the major networks but within three
years we successfully sold it to
Vodafone making millions of pounds but
without that vision at the outset my
business would not have gone the way
that it did
I started
telecoms business in 1998 and today it's
one of the most successful businesses of
its kind it generates income about 150
million pounds per annum all companies
have to start somewhere and my business
actually started in a tiny little office
in Slough
starting the business was a pretty
terrifying experience every single penny
that I had went into starting the
business but it kinda gave me a real
edge it gave me the sheer determination
that actually I could do this and as
each day in each week past when you get
more and more opportunities more and
more money comes into the business it
becomes even more exciting the size of
the office that I work from when I
started was 12 foot by 12 foot working
out of 12 foot by 12 foot was tough but
when you happen to live there as well it
makes it that much harder and what was
quite interesting
there are even employees in the company
that didn't know that I was staying and
sleeping and living in the office now
there are a few things that I learned
one was a sheer determination number two
was never giving up and number three was
to be results orientated I had to get
results if I wanted to get my life back
on track
I've been on an amazing journey since
then but I will never ever forget those
real real tough days to be perfectly
honest I'm a little bit confused myself
one minute I'm running a business next
minute I'm investing in one the next
minute I'm seeing some crazy people come
and pitch me a toilet snake idea from
Dragon's Den then I'm walking down the
BAFTAs or the red carpet Awards and then
I'm now trying to build a national
enterprise Academy yeah so I think if a
description of his own entrepreneur is
that I want to do it all before I die
then I'm that you need to research your
idea so that you've covered off not just
all the competition in the market but
you've checked and double-checked
whether your idea it's likely to work or
not so many people today start up a
business because they do it on the back
of a whim they need to research the
market they need to discuss how feasible
it is and then ask questions how am I
going to get out of the business Who am
I going to sell it to who are the
competitors in the market who are my
suppliers how much money do I need to
start the business how will i market the
company there's a lot to consider but
research of feasibility are
fundamentally important when starting a
new business number 6 is timing
supportive partners circumstances and
good health are all what I call critical
success factors when starting a new
business a new business venture will
require the majority of your time effort
and dedication times like this are very
difficult but I'm going to be a little
bit controversial and actually say that
for an entrepreneur this is the time and
there are many entrepreneurs that I
speak to that are out there that are
saying do you know what I'm please this
has happened this is a time for me now
to step up this is a time for my
business to really go up to the plate
this is the time where the competition
that was out there that wasn't that good
is disappearing recession in my mind can
drive innovation and the reason for that
quite simply is because we can do more
with less we are forced to do more
with less to take action so many people
talk about doing something or say what
if they don't actually get up and do it
taking action is really really important
in 1998 when I was working for another
company I was humming an airing of
whether to set up my own business I
didn't have a lot of money but I decided
to take action I decided to do it but I
did it in a very planned way I knew
exactly what I was going to do I knew
exactly what I wanted to achieve but the
most important thing I took action
within two or three years I was a
millionaire again probably the best
thing that I ever did so taking action
is absolutely vital successful
entrepreneurs have two undeniable
qualities determination and persistence
develop a keep on keeping on ability to
be called upon when ever you might need
it well you get things like this because
you know being blunt I've worked bloody
hard I wasn't born with a silver spoon
in my mouth and that's the great thing
that my life has given me now is that it
gives me freedom and it gives me choice
I can choose what I want to do when I
want to do it I don't have to work 16
hours a day I love working 16 hours a
day because I enjoy what I do
I get asked a lot do you really
appreciate what you've got I know it's
like to have everything to lose
everything so I'm not mister take it for
granted
I cherish what I have I'm lucky to have
it but boy do I make good use of it
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because I mean Abdul asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leaving the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of Peter
Jones's top 10 rules meant the most to
you had the biggest impact leave in the
comments and I'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon